the theory claims we all had these eight
intelligences and people differ from one
another and their profile of
intelligences and there's no necessary
link between one intelligence and the
other it also is based on the assumption
that we wouldn't have these
intelligences if they hadn't been
valuable in human evolution example I
like to use is that the we developed a
naturalist intelligence so we knew what
to eat and what not to eat and to be
able to pay attention to which animals
to run away from and which animals to
hunt and of course which plants to eat
and which ones so that mean there's a
reason why we're sensitive the world of
nature now most of us particular people
who would watch this or they go to
supermarkets and they don't have to know
anything about the wild but I think that
the the neural networks which evolved to
help us get around in the savannas of
East Africa 50,000 years ago they're now
being used for a consumer society and we
decide which shoes to buy which car to
buy and we're looking at the same kinds
of things that our ancestors did but
we're doing it in terms of walking
through a mall rest rather than walking
through the running through the the
savanna and hoping we won't get keeping
bias abide by some kind of a some kind
of a creature the history unfolds as
cultures evolve
of course the intelligences which they
value change I would say until a hundred
years ago if you wanted to have higher
education linguistic intelligence what
was important was important I teach in
Harvard in 125 years ago 150 years ago
the entrance exams were Latin Greek and
Hebrew and if for example you had you
were dyslexic that would be very
difficult because we hard for you to
learn those languages which are
basically written languages people don't
speak Greek when they when they learn
later in ancient Greek then over the
last century clearly the logical
mathematical intelligence is something
would pay a lot of attention to and the
linguistic intelligence is a little bit
more of an option
but once one looks at the world of
occupations we have hundreds of
occupations and I think the reason that
Dan Goldman's work on social and
emotional intelligence has got so much
attention is because while your your IQ
which is sort of language logic will get
you behind the desk if you don't know
how to deal with people you've known how
to be yourself you know you're going to
end up just staying at that desk forever
or eventually being asked to make room
for somebody who does have social or
emotional intelligence and when the
singularity occurs and the machines are
smarter than we are then it's the
artistic kinds of intelligence or
intelligence use artistic artistically
to be more precise which will come to
the fore
I think you can talk about reformism in
two senses one is it's clear that when I
developed this theory in the late 1970s
I was trying to reform the way
psychologists and other people think
about intelligence so certainly I had an
iconoclastic or reformist inclination
there and I was kind of surprised one
that the psychologist didn't all line up
in a row and say you're right we've been
wrong for a hundred years that somewhat
physicians but I was surprised at how
much interest there was within the
educational world and there I would say
gradually I switched from simply saying
this is how I think the mind is
organized and how it has developed to I
think maybe there are things we should
do things differently in education
because of the theory and then really in
the last 15 years I think I've become
much more reformist because I've been
concerned about the ethical dimensions
of our society that doesn't grow in any
natural way out of multiple
intelligences theory if we if I look at
it somewhat autobiographically as a
young person I was very much involved
with music I was a serious pianist and
while I never thought about a career in
music music was and has been very
important to me and then when I got to
college I became interested in the other
art forms and then I spent a year in
England as a fellow and I really
immersed myself in drama that's great to
do in theatre in London and art
galleries and sort of expanded my
artistic horizons and then when I be
went to graduate school in psychology I
was stunned at how the arts were never
mentioned to be a developed person
cognitively meant to be a scientist and
to think scientifically and we could
speculate about why that so but the
first serious book I wrote was called
the arts and human development and what
I said in that book this is in the early
70s as all developmental psychology has
thought of science as the apotheosis of
human development yet science is a
modern Western invention and we might
will never have invented science and you
had no Galileo and Copernicus and Newton
on the other hand arts exist in just
about every society and they're very
important so can we conceptualize
development in terms
the arts as well as the as the sciences
nowadays nobody takes extreme positions
on that issue maybe someday the press
will learn not to take extreme decisions
on the issue and I certainly believe
that every intelligence has a genetic
component how else would it exist and
every intelligence has a certain
heritability that's the technical term
for how much of the variation the
population has to do with who you I was
it with who your biological grandparents
were because that's a better set of
genes than your parents because you've
got four sets rather than then - we
don't know what the heritability is of
most intelligences but from a lot of
research we know that on the average
human traits are about 0.5 heritable so
you know that means that you know genes
make big contribution but so do parents
culture the media peers and so on I
guess I've never put it this way before
but maybe what I would say is you know
the intelligence is that you favor
probably ones where you have a genetic
predisposition but how you use those
intelligences is going to be
overwhelmingly determined by the culture
in which you're born and your parents
and what they value and whether you get
along with your parents and that kind of
thing so the deployment of intelligences
is probably largely a nurture factor but
you know if say by the BOK family had
loved genes going for it in the music
area and probably you know that was pre
pre pretty likely that they were going
to end up being musicians even if they
hadn't even if they've been so to speak
separated at birth and they've been
raised in another kind of family
the first thing I would say is that life
isn't fair and some people are going to
be strong a lot of intelligences and
some people aren't I think of the
intelligence as a set of computers and
if you wanted to summarize my theory in
a sentence we used to think there was
just one general computer in here if you
were good at one thing you'd be good at
everything if you're lousy in one thing
so kind of smarter across the board
stupid across the board I think the the
step I took I would call it in advance
is you can be very smart with language
average with music lousy with
understanding other people or vice-versa
there's no necessarily correlation
between the two but I think stupid has
two very different connotations one is
that your computer isn't very good for
example I'm very not biologically very
good spatially but the truth is with a
map and a position determiner and some
special attention to the environment I
can do perfectly perfectly well but I
suppose if there were a test of spatial
intelligence I wouldn't do very well so
one meaning for stupid is it takes you a
long time to do what it takes other
people who are smarter in that
intelligence I mean I'm very musical
especially when I was younger I heard
something once not only didn't could I
remember it I couldn't forget it and so
that's smart in that kind of a technical
sense but the other sense of stupid what
I think is much more important is how do
you go about leading your life you know
do you know what you're trying to do can
you achieve it when you make a mistake
do you make the same mistake again or do
you simply stick in a rut and you know
that has to do with your own
understanding of yourself what you're
trying to achieve what I call intra
personal intelligence and I'd much
rather to have somebody who was stupid
in the first sense but had a good sense
about how to negotiate their way through
life then somebody who had the computers
going full blast but kept knocking their
head against a wall I make fun of Mensa
I don't know agreed to about Mensa
that's the high IQ group but I say you
know to get into Mensa you have to have
a high IQ and once you get in you spend
your time congratulating people who are
in Mensa with you to me that's a pretty
stupid way to spend your life
course in American history but we've had
periods of greed and we've had periods
which were much more generous and I
think we're certainly have been in a
period of incredible greed
I think certainly dating back 20 or 30
years that's not going to be changed
overnight what I my perception is that
what societies do is a co-occurrence of
a set of ideas which are developed
usually by thinkers by think tanks and
with charismatic leaders who can bring
about those changes so to use things
which most people could have access to I
mean Franklin Roosevelt built very much
on the ideas of the progressive
Progressive Era which were developed in
the teens and then people like Barry
Goldwater Ronald Reagan Newt Gingrich
built very much on the neoconservative
ideas which were developed by William F
Buckley in his National Review and other
such thinkers in the 1950s and 60s what
I'm hoping is that some genuinely
progressive ideas some general liberal
ideas ideas for example social
entrepreneurship which have grown
enormously in the last 10 or 20 years
will intersect with a president who not
only totally gets it but has a generous
dollop of charisma I think what we're
realizing now is that this a significant
part of the population tends to be more
Republican than anything else who would
rather destroy the presidency and the
president then time to come to some kind
of an a belief that the country can and
should be should be different but it's a
huge educational effort education not
just in a sense I do it but in terms not
only of government but of private
leaders of philanthropists opinion
leaders and folks like me we're in the
trenches and they're not going to be up
there in the stage but who believe in
this and try to try to work on it and
Thomas Friedman who writes a lot about
this clearly is searching for a mission
for the United States because the United
States
has been essentially the world leader in
the last century in terms of policies
and of role models and he I think he
realizes that now a lot of things we
stand for is exactly what the world
doesn't want and doesn't need I think of
Obama doesn't succeed hopefully he will
serve two terms will be alive hopefully
he'll try if he doesn't succeed I think
it's going to be I think it means the
United States will be finished as a as a
moral force in the world and maybe
that's okay after all I'm not running
for office so I don't think the United
States is exceptional and I don't think
it has to be the moral leaders
not only have countries like Denmark and
Sweden that I know the best worked out
the best kind of balance of individual
initiative creativity entrepreneurship
with some kind of a concern not only
about the country but the rest of the
world but the people there are much
happier and I would love for someone to
do a detailed study of the United States
and particularly the people who are I'm
going to call the destroyers to see what
kind of understandings they really have
of the other possibilities I'd love to
know how many Americans have given the
choice of one in a million
becoming a trillionaire but actually
much more likely at the age of 55 losing
the job not being able to get another
one and would matter what their
insurance is the first time something
bad happens they get bankrupt well
making a little bit less money making
somewhat higher taxes but knowing that
the kids will have a decent education
that there's a safety net I'd like to
know how many people would really rather
choose the first because I don't know I
will say something which was a shock to
me and shows that I'm very much out of
the mainstream
some years ago I wrote an article for
foreign policy they said how could we
change things for the better and I know
they wanted me to write about education
but I'm free country happily said I
wrote about what I wanted and I said the
average household makes about $40,000 a
year I think that nobody in America
should be allowed to keep more than four
million dollars a year hundred times as
much they can make as much as they want
but anything above four million they
either have to give back to the
government or they have to set up a
charity then I said well people make
money for no more than 50 years so let's
multiply 4 million a year by 50 and we
get the 200 million I said no American
should be allowed to pass on to their
progeny more than 200 million again they
can make 200 trillion but everything
beyond that 200 million a sizeable sum I
think we would agree odd either to go to
back to the government origin some kind
of a 501c3 philanthropy I could not
believe the Gulf I got from people who
are wealthy people were average and
truck drivers and cab drivers they all
hated it because somehow I made it it's
mine and no one can take it away from me
that's insane it's insane
any analysis and yet I think that's what
we have breathin in our air probably to
some extent over hundreds of years but
certainly in that toxic Regan Gingrich
what did Reagan say government is not
the solution it's the problem we're
that's that's the that's the stuff we've
been stuck we've been sniffing it isn't
it isn't marijuana it's a it's it's that
markets can do no wrong
I've never met Obama I don't know
whether ever will but if I had 90
seconds with him in an elevator this is
what I would say mr. president American
society has been dominated by the three
MS money markets and me and especially
the young the best the brightest the
students that I work with they want to
be rich they believe totally in the
market even though that's a very
complicated thing it's all about me we
have to switch them first of all 90
degrees to the three es which I hope
will be visible on the camera excellence
engagement and ethics that's what I call
good work good workers of people who
know what they're doing are engaged in
it and try to do it in a responsible way
and then we flip the e another 90
degrees to w-4 we you can't ask other
people to be good workers unless you do
it yourself and join together to do good
work is the replacement for money
markets and me and the way that we
spread excellence engagement and ethics
I think that one of the good features
about the United States since I've been
bashing it is that it's built into our
DNA to take a chance and if we fail to
try again and that's why with the good
in the bad Hollywood Wall Street in
Silicon Valley all over the world our
icons particularly for young people
particularly young people with ambition
and I can remember back thirty years or
so ago I had a steady stream of people
from East Asia Chinese Korean and
Japanese saying we want to be creative
tell us the 23 steps to being creative
an order please
and I kept saying it doesn't work that
way basically I don't think I had the
word startup I said you got to try
something out try to get some other
people to support you and if it doesn't
work what it what can you learn from it
so I think it's it's in our it's in our
national DNA but creativity is
completely neutral it can be used
Osama bin Laden is very creative and
he's changed the history of the world
but I mean I don't think we really want
to gender more Osama bin Laden's Bill
Gates is is very creative but twenty
years ago a lot of us were pretty
critical about him and I think so to
speak he's redeemed himself by what he's
done with his with with his resources so
to me it's really wedding hour say the
the societal DNA for taking a chance
with doing doing something in a
responsible way one thing we have
learned though from our research
recently with young people and it's kind
of a surprise to me and these are again
rather privileged young people is
they're quite risk-averse and this is
especially in school they want to know
what's required of them what's the right
answer they don't want to take any
chances there and I even wonder if you
take a look at Wall Street and the the
major peccadilloes of the last 10 years
or so whether the young people were kind
of getting signals from their bosses
about what what's what they're supposed
to doing what they can do so that's a
that's a rather different view of
creativity than Thomas Edison alone in
his lab you know coming coming up with
new ideas and and trying them out so I
guess
this with this soliloquies is convincing
me of is creativity isn't kind of a
fixed entity over the time and over the
over the mill year and clearly the the
secret is to is to bottle up what what
we've done well but not to assume that
it's going to be done exactly you
creativity used to be sitting alone in a
garret in Paris or tinkering with your
test tubes in New Jersey or being a
patent officer in in Baron Switzerland
and now it's global and how that takes
place when everybody's connected to
everybody else when any artwork can be
initially not only transmitted but
morphed and photoshopped and flickered
and message messed around and so on when
we need to have different analytic tools
than we had in the days of solitary
creativity
what's interesting in our own study is
we have what we call the good play
project which is about kids and and
computers is that every child of a young
person is wired now and most older
people as well
the overwhelming uses either social
networking which is basically hanging
around the front of school but doing it
now 24/7 wherever you are gaming some
games are intellectually challenging but
a lot of them are just can you get the
other guy before he gets you there
usually guys then and here I'm talking
about the work of Mimi Ito in particular
there's some what we call messing around
where people have ideas and interests
and pursue them a bit but the way in my
day I would write a book about something
and talk to some people than read got
another way and then there there's you
know what what's called geeking or
geeking out people getting seriously
interested in things and that's still a
small percentage of the population
whether it's bigger than before and I
can't judge and the I haven't hold
enough to have lived through the
promises the educational promises of
radio television the film strip DVDs CDs
and so on of course school hasn't
changed very much I do believe that the
new digital media would change education
radically and they'll change workplace
radically
Wiki government by simone novak argues
very persuasively that in things like
giving a patent we can make use of
expertise in the population and in fact
it's probably imperative because they're
way too many applications and the Patent
Office is overwhelmed it takes years for
it to make a decision and they only
almost always say yes because they don't
have a good argument to say no now if
you simply were to post an idea for an
invention and let everybody in the world
say whether it should be patented that's
nonsense
because 99% of people would have no idea
about how to analyze it and wouldn't
have the knowledge to know whether it
was original or not so the idea of wiki
government and it seems to work in the
patent area is that people have to be
technical enough to be able to read the
stuff and to be able to comment in a
appropriate way and ultimately raters
themselves will be rated the way there
are an ebay so if john smith pipes up
all the time but what he has to say is
nonsense he gets a very low rating and
the decision in the end is made by the
US Patent Office and they see which
people to pay attention to and which not
that seems to me on the face of it to be
a plan where it taking seriously on the
other hand all you would need to have
three multinationals who decide to
corrupt the process by pretending to
fakery the way many people on the left
and the right have thousands of emails
sent to a political candidate and if the
clinical candidate isn't sharp they
think it's their their own constituents
rather than you know IBM or whatever
paying for it
this badou gaming the system is not
going to disappear just because some
people have a good idea of how to use
latex / tees
well I give an honest answer number one
is I sleep very well number two
I'm much more likely to be kept up by
family kinds of problems especially ones
which I think that I should be able to
solve that I can then by by cosmic
problems but what gets me to work each
day and I think that's the deeper
question that you're asking is whether
there's anything that I can do in any
particular role to nudge upward the the
amount of good work that's done work
that's excellent
engaging in ethical and I made a big
decision five or six years ago to begin
to work much more with young students
secondary students college students
trying to get them to think about
ethical issues at a time when they
aren't already having to hit a payroll
and do what the boss says and I'm still
feeling my way I've worked at three
colleges and my team has worked at many
many secondary schools all over the
world and I wouldn't at all say that
we've discovered the magic way of doing
it but I'm a great believer that people
cannot deal with any kind of complex
issue unless they've had to engage and
think about it discuss it roleplay and
so on and when I began a good work
project with my colleagues one of them
bill Damon said if I could cure cancer
bill said I would he said I can't I
think working a good work is the most
important thing that I can do and I
agree with him I think that's the most
important thing that I can do and I try
to use everything he including this one
to raise people's consciousness about it
I mean the problem has story
historically was people could be very
bad workers and they could destroy their
society but the rest of the planet would
survive now we're all we ended all
together you know whether it's a disease
or money or human beings we circulate
all around the world somebody who wants
to do mischief could destroy the planet
it could destroy all the people on it
and unless we develop the good work
muscle regionally locally nationally
and internationally there won't be a
plan
that's pretty easy because whenever I
describe IQ tests I say that IQ tests
take have a combination of language and
logic and if you do well in language and
logic if you can combine them you'll
have a high IQ and I say that's a
selector for who will be a law professor
and I then mentioned Bill Clinton
Hillary Clinton and Barack Obama who all
three of them were law professors and
clearly they have the IQ kind of
intelligence it's absolutely clear to me
that Obama has enormous intrapersonal
intelligence his book Dreams to my
father is an amazing book and it's
obviously everybody has lots of control
personal intelligence but here's the
here's the big question we don't know
and that is um what is this existential
intelligence like existential
intelligence is one that I use kind of
playfully and that's the interest in big
questions there's no doubt that he's
interested in these himself but it's not
clear to what extent he's such a
pragmatist that he will lose that sense
of mission that bigger story John
Kennedy really achieved nothing
practically as president but he had
enormous power to excite people to
motivate them to think differently and
that's why we still remember him you
know 50 years after the fact and I'm not
sure speaking now in September of oh
nine whether the existential
intelligence which Obama clearly has in
his own life is something that he can
mobilize more I mean you know Ronald
Reagan was able to mobilize that I don't
like what he did but there was no
question that he helped people think
about meaning and we thought that Obama
could but it's a it's just not clear at
this point
Derek Bock who is the president of
Harvard used to have this quote I don't
know that it's originally with him which
is if you think education is expensive
try estimating the cost of ignorance and
the truth is until century or so ago
formal education for the elite was fine
but there was really no need to educate
the mass of society at least beyond the
basic literacies but now it is
completely obvious that unless people
are not only educated to a higher level
but want to continue to learn actually
motivated to continue to learn don't
feel it's a gun to their head that there
will not be very useful to themselves or
to their society the problem is that a
small proportion of the population gets
a very good education at the short end I
would say the International
Baccalaureate crowd which is a kind of
Education which elites are able to get
whether or not they belong to the IB but
of course that's expensive education and
it presupposes a lot of parental and
teacher support in large parts of the
world that's just not not a practical
reality and that's why people who are in
policy which I don't think about much
more macro things ranging from One
Laptop Per child toward making sure that
women are able to go to school to
ensuring that the country isn't last on
some kind of international comparison
and we can't think about education in
that is as if it's were as if it were
just one thing my focus has been on
educational aspirations but that's an
ideal and I'm quite aware that it's
easier to achieve at Phillips Academy
Andover than it is in a one-room
schoolhouse in Bangladesh with 60 kids
not enough food to heat and if I can
close with one sentence I think that the
major problem with the No Child Left
Behind policy which is completely
bipartisan policy is it uses the country
to solve the problems of inner city
Detroit or DC and that's just mixing
apples and oranges the way I've put it
the problem in the inner-city is
excellence the problem in the heartland
is engagement the problem among the
elites